[Musique]
je voulais vraiment un sport de contact
est vraiment physique donc j'ai trouvé
le rugby j'ai vraiment j'adore ça me
permet un peu de me détendre débat des
fois je suis juste en colère je me dis
fin du rugby ça me détendre j'aime bien
autres garçons que les filles c'est pas
des mauviettes quoi donc montrer qu'on
est présentée on est capable aussi de de
se battre mais tu sais très bien qu
rester dans lequel faut rester dans
lequel fois les bien aimés témoin
plusieurs sipa valeurs de respect de
l'adversaire de dead dead entre entre
soi puisque leur dit fondamentalement
c'est une porteuse de ballons et toutes
ses copines sont derrière elle donc
forcément ses copines elles vont à
soutenir et l'aider à avancer pour aller
vers un but commun qui est marqué oui
c'est toutes ces valeurs cancale il
arrive à inculquer à travers ce stade
non rugby tu as le droit que de faire
des passes vers l'arrière t'as jamais le
droit de faire une passe vers l'avant si
elle était devant toi ok avance avance
avec ton ballon mais pas peur du contact
essaye essaye top avance avance avance
avant c'était une belle ambiance et on
s'entend tous bien il n'y a pas une
personne qui sera à l'écart les
nouvelles elles vont s'incruster très
rapidement donc c'est enfin vous c'est
sympa ok on me fais attention tu es un
peu en dessous l'a fait attention pour
toi c'est un peu dangereux au rugby ça
n'empêche pas du tout d'être féminine 1
j'ai l'impression oui et non pas du tout
bas après c'est sûr que ça nous fait
prendre des épaules mais ça nous empêche
pas d t min on s'habille comme tout le
monde
il n'y a pas de problème pour ça non non
on a vu ce qu'on a les cheveux attachés
en transpire mais sinon ça nous empêche
toujours pas de kevin vit à chaque fois
qu on dit dans notre école ont fait du
rugby on nous regarde
vous oui nous c'est pas parce qu'on est
petit qu'on est grande quand les grosses
on a tout le monde fait du rugby
différents postes si justement c'est
pour ça aussi c'est un sport d'équipé et
dans ses bons scores de mecs j'ai ma
soeur qui voulut en équipe de france
moins de 20 ans et c'est vraiment une
fierté j'ai envie de jouer de suivre sa
destinée de suivre ses pas d'arriver à
ce niveau à atteindre le niveau cas là
[Applaudissements]
à